NASA's celebrating
after a mission
that's simply out of this world.
Touchdown pirate radio
30 has touchdown.
NASA has collected an asteroid s
from space. That's right.
The capsule that scooped up
the rock ended its seven year jo
this morning, landing in the Uta
Scientists
hope the large chunk
of space rock will help
NASA learn more
about the origins of our solar s
No small thing.
Let's bring in World
Renowned astrophysicist Neil
deGrasse Tyson,
whose latest book,
To Infinity
and Beyond A Journey of Cosmic
Discovery, was just released thi
Neil, it looks like another grea
As always, we appreciate you com
How amazing was this?
What NASA's pulled off today
Well, I like to think of the big
First credit goes to the enginee
There are scientists all through
but the engineers made it work.
So that not enough
at tipping goes to the engineers
We launch a space.
We launch a space probe from Ear
itself, a moving platform to int
an asteroid itself, a moving tar
It then touches and go
does it
touch and go
off of that asteroid surface?
And grabbing any thing it could?
When it hit, we
we expected maybe a couple of ou
but it got like a half
a pound of material,
got grabbed up into the capsule.
Then that
continued on to intersect Earth,
that capsule.
And then it kept going
and it's on to another asteroid
And so, yes, it is rocket scienc
And yes, it's a it's a brilliant
And I look forward to more of th
in the future.
Absolutely.
And what are we hoping to learn
from all this?
I mean, it's a long way to go.
It's a complicated mission.
There's got to be a good
reason behind it.
All evidence suggests that the a
are relics
of the formation of the solar sy
Four and a half billion years ag
And think about it on Earth's su
there's nothing that old.
It's been subducted
coming in and out of volcanoes.
The just the everything gets
interfered with when you're on a
But if you're freely floating in
you have the pristine ingredient
And what is likely we'll find is
Molecules.
You know,
we think Earth is some special p
to form
organic chemistry,
no carbon, oxygen, nitrogen.
These elements, these organic
basic ingredients
in some asteroids we have known
have formed amino
acids, the building blocks of pr
itself, a building block for lif
So there's a treasure
trove of chemical information
available to us.
Right. Ready when they open the
And one of the things
I think is interesting about us
messing with this asteroid
is that and correct me
if I'm wrong here, Neil, help me
Apparently, this asteroid is a l
of a tricky thing out there in s
And that maybe in 100 or 200 yea
it might slam into Earth, which
doesn't sound so good.
So I guess
being able to
fly something over there
and landing it on there,
that might
give us some faith that perhaps
what we might be able to knock i
course or something down the roa
help us
fill in the gaps
precisely unlike what they tried
unlike what they try to do in th
which is like destroy it.
That's unrealistic.
Typically,
given the mass of these asteroid
asteroid Bennu
from which this sample was remov
is larger than the Empire State
And so what you want to do
is deflect them,
either deflect them
so that they pass ahead of Earth
or behind Earth and not hit us d
And so the more we know about as
especially the structural integr
because some asteroids
we have come to
discover are loosely held
together, rubble piles.
And so if you nudge on one part
it could just break off that pie
without much affecting the rest.
So the more we understand about
not only what they're made of,
how they're held together,
it will enable us to plan future
missions of deflection.
And by the way, that risk of hit
is about one in 3000 at this mom
but it's 150 years away.
That's a perfect time
frame to do something.
Yeah.
So let's get on that
point, trying to raise money
and figure that out.
We know
that's not large enough
to make it extinct,
but it would do damage
if we suffer from an impact.
We have no excuse
because we have good
orbital orbital dynamics
describing what that risk is.
Yeah,
plenty of time to give Bruce Wil
and Aerosmith ready.
I remember that movie
I've apologize for that.
And I have to apologize
for the next thing
I'm going to ask you, Neil,
because I feel embarrassed
asking you
something like this, but
what is going on with these alie
Down in Mexico?
The alien bodies, these purporte
alien bodies shown at this UFO
hearing down in Mexico.
I have to get you
to weigh in on this
because obviously this looks
ridiculous and fake,
but why do we keep getting sucke
into this stuff
and your thoughts when you saw t
Well, I said finally,
the aliens are being brought for
in all of our testimonies in Con
They're in a lock box
you know, in the back room.
So, right.
Finally, we get to look at the a
That's step one.
Step two is the reports of one i
or one group or not.
What establishes
an objective truth in science?
Nor does holding your hand up,
swearing that you're telling the
that has it.
It's irrelevant
What matters is
do other labs
get the same results you do?
That's what matters.
I was a little worried
that that whole display there
in front of a green screen
you know,
because had never a good thing
about the people
putting anything behind it.
So what you do now is share thes
with other labs,
skeptical labs around the world.
And if they get the same results
you got something.
That's what we did with the moon
when we brought them back.
We spread them into the labs of
so they could
participate in this moving
frontier of discovery.
And until that happens,
it's a sideshow at this point.
And to make it to end it on a so
more serious note,
given that
we are developing the technology
to land rockets
on asteroids and collect samples
and that sort of thing,
do you think that there might be
it might be a moment in the
not so distant future
where we will
eventually develop the technolog
to detect some kind of organism
living organism
other than ourselves
out there in the cosmos?
Do you have any kind of a major
Yeah, major driver. Of NASA.
And NASA
has had a mantra
for the past several decades.
Follow the water on Earth.
Wherever there's liquid water,
there is life.
Even the Dead Sea has life.
Just doesn't have macroscopic fi
Whoever named it
the Dead Sea didn't have a micro
Okay, so that's true.
So we've been thought
there's water on Mars
on Jupiter's
moon, Europa,
and beneath the frozen surface,
by the gravitational stress
coming from Jupiter
and surrounding moons.
And that's it's
an ocean of liquid water,
more water than is here
in Earth's oceans.
And it's been liquid
for billions of years.
So, yeah,
I want to go ice fishing on Euro
to see.
Yeah, something happened there
similar to what happened here on
So this has been a major search.
The fact that some UFOs and alie
show up. Okay.
But we're we're actively looking
and we need something
better than a fuzzy image.
And the new hearings in Congress
where they're now inviting peopl
to have to send in their data.
We all have high resolution
data detection device.
Perfect time
to crack to crack the
nut of all of the UFO UAPs.
Sorry, they were rebranded.
That's right. The government.
Yes, it's the same that that you
it is.
And we'd certainly like to see t
one of these days forward.
Yeah, yeah.
I hope nobody doesn't
want to meet the aliens
and not be aliens.
I worry that they maybe have vis
what they landed
like during Comic-Con
and then they just got complimen
for the guts to deal with it
when we do meet them one day.
I know, I know. I'm a U.S.
ambassador. Yeah,
well, yeah,
it says, take me to your leader.
I ain't taking them to the presi
I'm taking it to my
my own people at NASA,
at the National Academy of Scien
I'm not taking them
to a single politician. No. All
Good deal.
All right, Neil, great to see, a
Thanks so much. Appreciate it.
Thanks for having me. Right back
The truth is out there.
We'll be right back.